jd is still not exercising and he thinks
listen to this
he thinks he weighs 215 pounds what
i know my i know my weight officially
now uh it's 217 at the moment
right as it was yesterday at least i'll
tell you wow
that's come under some debate uh i i've
thought i was five eight but i got
people telling me i'm five nine so
uh do you know anyone who doesn't know
how tall they are no
i mean i couldn't i don't know how tall
you are like how
are you so not aware of your own height
listen we've done this
i've had this discussion before and i
could have swore we we
we not weighed but we uh hided myself we
measured
whatever we measured what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
i i hided myself i corrected myself
uh well i measured how high uh uh how
tall how tall
yes yes and uh i thought it was five
eight but uh you know i don't know
because i slouch too i i don't like
stand up straight
i don't stand up straight but i know my
height okay well it's been it's been
years since i've like
done my height i don't uh like i said
you finished growing around i don't know
at the most like
21 years old you'd be done you're not a
tree dude
it's like i know a tree okay you know
hey that tree used to be a lot taller
you know something happened to the tree
you're a person
by the age of 18 or 1920 with the latest
you kind of know your height listen i i
haven't thought about it that much i
guess i don't this is crazy
oh well i'm crazy i don't know what to
tell you i'm five eight sure thank you
are you five eight or you but now
they're saying you're five nine
i'm probably five eight i don't know
where does five nine talk to you do you
wanna
find out how tall you are i'm not
worried about it right now i'm not
leaving the house
for christ's sake i don't need nowhere i
just think it's funny that someone
wouldn't know their own height
i really do i i i
don't know what to tell you you know
what it says here at your height
if you're five eight or five nine you
qualify as obese
all right that's crazy dude
stand up let me see your belly howard's
gonna do a tv show about you you keep
this up
wow it doesn't look that bad i mean
you're obese no he's holding it together
i saw a picture of you the other day
when you first joined our show
you were a skinny guy i mean you had a
nice physique
you know what the my dna changed i don't
know what to tell you my uh
you put a piece of tape over your mouth
your dna will go back
you